Now, if the image of complexity classes that are just true look a bit complicated to you,
I would have to say you haven't seen anything yet,
because, of course, they are many many more complexity classes out there.
Basically, any type of machine and restriction that you can think of forms a complexity class.
And a nice collection of this, if you're interested in that, is the complexity zoo
initiated by Scott Aaronson, a theoretical computer scientist at the MIT,
and here we have a nice formatting of this document as a PDF, but it is also a website.
So Google the complexity zoo. It's really interesting to see.
And as you can see here in the glossary, there are many many many more complexity classes
than ones that we talked about.
So let's just see if we can find those that we already know.
Here's FPT. This is the class of fixed-parameter tractable problems. Here is P.
Down here somewhere is NP, but you see it's already difficult to find
even those classes that we know, because they are so many different other ones.
And they have lots of different origins, so there are some classes that are related to approximation,
some classes that are related to randomization, and many classes here are also
related to special models of computation that we haven't had the time to cover in this course.
So there are some models of computation that work with circuits for example
or even more exotic models such as quantum computing.
The bad news about all of these classes here or all of the classes here in this document is that
we don't really know much about the relationships between them.
We know some, but as you have seen with P versus NP, there are lots of open questions here,
which I think is also a good news for you.
There are still lots and lots and lots of things to explore in computational complexity.